Have you joined any of the school clubs?
No, I haven't joined any clubs.
But I decided to join the basketball club.
I think joining clubs is very important.
Definitely! It's a great way to meet people, also a way to have a lot of fun.
Actually, I've already made up my mind to join.
How about you, Kathy? Are you a member of any clubs here?
Yes, I am, actually.
Have you heard of the "Friends of the Disabled" club?
No, I don't think I have.
Do you work with disabled people?
Yes, we do. Both kids and adults.
Last Saturday, we took a  group of kids to the park and taught them how to in-line skate.
Hey, that sounds really great!
Maybe I will join your club, too.
Sure! Just let me know.
New people are always welcome.
Okay, I'm definitely going to do that then. Thanks.